is this crazy story The Wall Street
Journal looked at this previously we
reported that thieves are stealing
people's iPhones and passcodes new
warning about iPhone thefts connected to
your passcode and then taking over these
victims financial and digital lives that
was chapter one this is chapter two I
went to visit my buddy in Chicago
and my phone was stolen
and the thieves were able to generate a
recovery key
which would lock me out of my my iCloud
account I'm willing to do anything
possible just to get my photos and
videos back
access iCloud account my inbox has been
flooded with notes from people like Greg
who can't get back into their apple
accounts to access years of photos
videos and more it's the collateral
damage caused by a hidden iPhone setting
enabled by the thieves the killer has
been the recovery key so I dug into the
secret setting and found out that it's
flawed
crimes like this across the country use
the passcode to turn on the recovery key
before they steal money from apps on the
phone
this way the owners can't remotely get
back in to wipe the device and use find
my iPhone
to understand how thieves exploit these
vulnerabilities think of your Apple
account like a house
the thieves get in and then keep you out
by changing the main lock on the front
door your Apple account password yes
with the passcode to your iPhone they
can change the Apple account password
it's a major vulnerability in itself
which I talked about a lot in that first
video
now if a victim wants to get back in
they go through account recovery aka the
old forgot your password reset process
Apple will ask for your trusted phone
number provide that and a texted code
and you should be able to create a new
password to unlock the front door
but many of these thieves put up more
barriers they change the trusted phone
number and or create a recovery key
under settings Apple ID password and
Security account recovery you can turn
on a recovery key which creates a unique
28 character code it is now needed to
get to the step of changing your account
password if you don't have that code
Apple says you could be locked out of
your account permanently aka the door
can never be opened when you call Apple
and you tell them you don't have the
recovery key what do they tell you to an
extent they told me you know too bad so
sad there was no possible way to
regenerate the recovery key or to get
access to my data without that specific
recovery key contacted Apple support
many levels try to escalate that I've
went through Apple legal who pushed me
back to Apple support I've spoken to
many attorneys trying to figure out a
course of action to get my data back but
I reached out to Apple about all this a
spell I spoke said
who had this experience and we take all
attacks on our users very seriously no
matter how rare
we work tirelessly every day to protect
our users accounts and data and we are
always investigating additional
protections against emerging threats
like this one
the recovery key was supposed to add
Extra Protection to your Apple account
from online hackers but there's a big
flaw even if someone like Greg already
had the setting turned on a thief with
the iPhone's passcode could create a new
key right on the device which would
replace the old one
Apple designed this as a convenience
measure for people who misplaced a
previously generated key fundamentally
account recovery is about proving that
this account is yours Greg and many
others I've spoken to have offered Apple
other forms of identification to prove
that I've been willing to give Apple any
piece of identification or verifiable
information that I am me and this is my
account whether or not that be my ID my
passport my social security number of
course there's a reason Apple doesn't
keep your social security number on file
privacy there is one thing you can do
right now to prevent this from happening
if your iPhone were ever stolen go to
settings screen time use screen time
passcode and create a passcode that's
different from your main phone passcode
now go to screen time content and
privacy restrictions
then turn on this switch scroll down to
the allowed changes section where it
says account changes and select don't
allow now a thief wouldn't be able to
get into this area to change your
account password or turn on that
recovery key they would need that screen
time passcode but clearly there is far
more for Apple to do here to protect us
from crimes like this the recovery key
policies should be changed so that it's
not the only way to get back into an
account once it's activated and apple
should certainly restrict the recovery
key from being so easily deleted or
regenerated by someone who has your
phone and passcode and apple should
provide another way to confirm people
are who they are possibly by accepting
government IDs ultimately this entire
crime is based around Apple loopholes a
stolen phone passcode and tap of a
button shouldn't mean fighting one of
the world's largest companies to get our
memories back at this point I'm willing
to offer Apple whatever it takes to get
my pictures and videos back whether it's
tens of thousands of dollars
a retina scan a DNA test whatever it
takes